language and speech has evolved in human  beings thousands of years ago and  language is something that connects us  to each other and we build up society  we always wonder whether our  evolutionary cousins neanderthals can  speak like humans and the answer may be  found in human gene  one gene known as fox p2 is known as  language associated gene because  mutation in this gene cause language  impairment  scientists wondered whether this  particular gene is different between  neanderthal and humans so they did high  throughput sequencing and found  this gene is strikingly similar between  human and neanderthal but both of them  are different from chimpanzee that means  the common ancestor of these two  human species  has the same gene and they might have  the ability to process language further  looking at the skull we can understand  the er cavity structure is pretty  similar and capable of processing